Simplifica "3a" a la quinta entre "9a" cuadrada
por "a" cuarta entre "a" cúbica.
Así que antes de preocuparnos acerca de las "a",
podemos simplificar el 3 y el 9,
ambos son divisibles entre 3.
Así es que dividamos el numerador
y el denominador entre 3.
Tenemos entonces que 3 entre 3 es igual a 1
y 9 entre 3 es igual a 3.
La expresión queda entonces como 1 por "a" a la quinta, por "a" a la cuarta entre...
o más precisamente debo de decir,
"a" quinta sobre "3a" cuadrada,
por "a" cuarta sobre "a" cúbica.
Ahora multiplicando estas 2 expresiones,
¿qué tenemos?
Que esto es igual a "1a" a la quinta
por "a" a la cuarta
y el 1 no me tengo que preocupar,
no afecta la expresión, entonces sería en el numerador, "a" a la quinta por "a" a la cuarta,
todo eso dividido entre 3...
déjame poner el 3 mejor acá,
3 por "a" cuadrada por "a" cúbica
y a partir de aquí, hay muchísimas maneras
en que podemos simplificar esto.
Una de ellas,
a veces denominada la regla del cociente,
es aquella que establece que si tenemos
"a" elevada a la "x" sobre "a" elevada a la "y",
esto es igual a "a" elevada a la "x" menos "y",
y para que podamos entender el porqué esto funciona, pensemos en "a" a la quinta entre "a" a al cuadrado.
Entonces tenemos que "a" a la quinta,
lo podemos escribir como
"a", por "a", por "a", por "a", por "a",
esto de aquí es "a" a la quinta
dividido entre "a" cuadrada...
lo voy a poner con este color...
"a" cuadrada que es "a" por "a",
esto de aquí es "a" cuadrada.
Ahora claramente podemos ver
que tanto el numerador como el denominador,
son divisibles por "a" por "a", es decir,
podemos dividir ambos entre "a" por "a".
Así que dividiendo el numerador entre "a" 2 veces
nos deshacemos de estas dos "a"
y el denominador,
al dividirlo entre "a" dos veces nos resulta 1.
¿Qué tenemos entonces?
Aquí tenemos que el numerador es,
"a" por "a", por "a" dividido entre 1,
es decir,
esto es igual a "a", por "a", por "a"
"a" multiplicada por sí misma 3 veces,
es decir esto es igual a "a" al cubo,
"a" a  la 5 menos 2,
que es igual a "a" cúbica.
Teníamos 5, cancelamos 2,
y nos resultaron 3.
Así que apliquemos esa regla por acá,
y te voy a mostrar 2 maneras de hacer esto.
Entonces primero apliquemos la regla del cociente,
"a" a la quinta sobre "a" al cuadrado...
déjame indicar esto de la siguiente manera...
primero haremos "a" a la quinta sobre "a" al cuadrado,
para posteriormente hacer "a" a la cuarta
sobre "a" cúbica,
por supuesto considerando 1/3 por delante.
Entonces ahora la expresión queda como
1/3
por "a" a la quinta,
entre "a" al cuadrado...
"a" a la quinta entre "a" al cuadrado,
que fue lo que hicimos por acá,
esto es "a" al cubo por
"a" a la cuarta entre "a" cúbica...
déjame hacerlo con el mismo azul que tenemos aquí...
esto es "a"...
no, no es el mismo azul.
Tenemos que esto es "a"...
no, tampoco es el mismo azul.
Ahora sí, esto es "a" a la cuarta sobre "a" cúbica,
que es "a" a la 4 menos 3 que es "a" a la 1,
y por supuesto, esto lo podemos simplificar como,
"a" cúbica por "a" a la 1...
déjame hacerlo mejor por acá arriba...
Aquí tenemos "a" la elevada a la tercera potencia,
por "a" elevada a la potencia 1.
Tenemos la misma base,
podemos sumarlos exponentes.
Aquí tenemos "a" al cubo
que es "a" multiplicada por sí misma 3 veces,
por una vez "a", esto va a ser entonces
"a" elevada a la cuarta, que es "a" a la 3 más 1.
Esto multiplicado por supuesto por 1/3
resulta 1/3 a la cuarta,
lo cual también se puede escribir como
"a" a la cuarta dividida entre 3.
Ahora la otra manera de hacer este ejercicio era
aplicar la regla del producto,
sumando los exponentes para el numerador,
y luego sumando los exponentes para el denominador.
Así que aplicando la regla del producto para el numerador,
no aplicamos la regla de cocientes,
esa la vamos a aplicar después.
Tenemos el numerador
"a" a la quinta por "a" a la cuarta
eso es "a" a la 9, "a" a la 5 más 4,
dividido entre "a" cuadrada por "a" al cubo,
"a" al cuadrado por "a" al cubo,
es "a" a la 2 más 3
podemos sumar los exponentes
tenemos la misma base, esto es "a" a la quinta
y también tenemos el 1/3
que escribimos como 3 en el denominador,
y ahora, y ahora podemos aplicar
la propiedad del cociente para exponentes.
Aquí tenemos "a" a la novena,
sobre "a" a la quinta,
"a" a la novena potencia,
sobre "a" la quinta potencia,
aplicando la regla del cociente es "a" a la 9 menos 5,
que es "a" a la cuarta potencia
y por supuesto,
también tenemos aquí el 3 en el denominador,
como puedes ver de cualquier manera,
obtuvimos la misma respuesta.